(film rolling)
(beep)
♪ Start of my life was kinda rough ♪
♪ I had an uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Perspective is the game ♪
♪ I GaryVee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head down ♪
♪ Do the work and everything will change ♪
♪ Sippin' tea help the fields ♪
♪ Yeah that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient hella
tricky if I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Preaching positivity ♪
- Morning, morning, morning,
morning, morning, morning.
It is Thursday, June 25th,
and this Tea with GaryVee.
Big shout out to
everybody in the comments.
Good morning, Tammy J.?
Jorge Mike Swagger, what's good?
It'sTheRealHope in the building.
Lucio, Lazette, what's good?
Tarel Hope, great to see you.
KJ Trimming in the building.
Big shout out to Twitch, and
to Facebook, and to Periscope,
and to LinkedIn, and to Instagram.
Everybody, great to see.
24/7 Fishings in the building.
Before we start, go right up to the URL,
go right up to the URL
right out and share it,
share it on Twitter, share it on Facebook,
please take a screenshot and
put in your Instagram stories.
Let's get people on the dirty
tea with Tea with GaryVee.
And I'm excited about this episode
as you can tell by the energy,
so let's get right into it.
Good morning, good morning, good morning,
good morning, good morning.
Tommy Brown, what's good?
- What's good, how are you feeling?
- I'm feeling great.
How are you?
- Man, I'm doing excellent,
I can't complain.
- Where are you at?
- LA.
- Thanks for getting up early.
- Yeah, 100%.
Not usually up this time,
I'm usually going to sleep this time.
- (laughs) But, well, it's
great to see you, man.
What can I answer for you?
- Good to see you too.
I was gonna ask you, like,
with the success of all
the apps like TikTok
and everything else,
where do you see the music
industry going in the future?
Like not just being the
traditional record label,
but do you think it's
possible that like TikTok
or any of these apps can
be a future record label?
- I think they could.
I don't think they will.
I think TikTok's MTV 1985,
it's kinda where all the kids are,
and then thus whatever
music's popping, it pops.
I think you've seen what
Spotify, and really,
SoundCloud more than anything has done,
which is you don't need a
record label to get exposure.
I think the leverage
that the internet gives
to the artists versus the distribution,
it's always a content
and distribution game.
And the record labels had
all the leverage for so long
because you couldn't get
your music to the world
unless you were signed,
had a CD or a record,
put in Sam Goody or a Virgin store,
and then you gotta get promoted on TRL.
Like that was the machine.
Now, me and you can go
into the studio at 4 a.m.,
back to your point earlier,
usually up, hit something,
I got real fucking cloud out
here, put it on my thing,
we'll link it to
SoundCloud, it gets going,
you start making bean culture.
You look at Old Country Road,
the game of completely flipped.
Look, could they?
Sure, they could, more
likely in those platforms,
but we should wanna stay neutral
and have everybody come into them
because that's even more
business, that's the distribution.
And as soon as they start a label,
they alienating other
people that are out there.
And so TikTok doesn't wanna lose Rihanna
because they started a
label and came up Schmianna,
and they compete for sound.
So I think it's more about
using those platforms
and understanding that,
if I'm an artist, I build as big as I can,
have all the leverage.
And then I think record
labels are gonna have
to evolve into things like,
they're gonna have to show value.
They can't just do distribution.
So I think record labels
are gonna have to be able
to build you.
A lot of the way I think
about the vending machine,
like what I've deployed
against my wine business
and how I think about music
and film and everything is,
eventually, the only thing
that's gonna matter is
if somebody can actually
get you more awareness,
because everything else is a commodity.
- Yeah, 100%, 'cause It's
crazy to see the bump.
And there's producers
and artists that I know
that now have real records
that never would get a deal before.
And they're 35 years old with a song
that's number one on TikTok.
- This is all I've been yelling
about for fucking 15 years.
And obviously, when TikTok, and musically,
and then became TikTok,
like, I've been screaming about this,
and nobody believes it.
So few believe it.
Definitely not people that
are a little further along.
The people that have no choice believe it,
they're like, "Yeah," well, to your point,
"Nobody's gonna sign me,
nobody gives a fuck, I'm 35."
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The people I worry about are the ones
that got a little something going,
have signed a deal, are in the game.
'Cause they don't realize that
they kinda look at it as like,
"Fuck, I've been grinding
out here for 15 years
to just get to this spot."
You know?
- Yeah, 100%, 100%.
- And I'm like, "No, no, don't
do that, go all in on that."
Look at Jason Derulo.
- Yeah, he's a good friend
of mine, he's like smash,
it's insane.
- And it makes me so happy for him
'cause he's like almost
like the DJ Khaled of this.
Khaled had a real career, but
Snapchat changed his life.
- 100%.
- Jason had a real career,
but let's not get it twisted,
his relevance score has gone
through the fucking roof.
- 100%.
- 17-year-olds
that knew Jason was like that,
and in six months, they love the man.
- 25 million followers, it's insane.
- And now, he can like take a step back
and really put out a track, a record,
or fucking drop something,
and it's gonna work.
And a year ago, if he dropped
that, it wasn't gonna work.
That's just real life.
- Just insane how it changed
the game, it's insane.
- And it will continue to happen.
Today it's TikTok, tomorrow,
something called like Slinky
Red is gonna come out,
and it's where,
like this is just a culture,
youth culture will always be like this.
It's gonna always be like this.
- Yeah, I think record labels
are forever changed now.
- And they have to now bring
value in a different way.
And that's it,
and so I say it.
- 100%.
- Keep pushing Tommy, I
really appreciate it, man.
Everybody follow the man.
You have a good day.
- Yeah, I appreciate it.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Yeah, listen, and the game
is changing in everything.
Real estate,
like when I think about the power
of like being a great communicator
and having a machine behind it,
if I wanna start Vayner Realty,
if I wanna start Vayner Records,
if I wanna start Vayner Films,
all of those things are gonna do better
because I've been focused on the thing
that actually matters,
which is getting fucking people to see it.
Not get it out into the world,
I can put a movie on the fucking internet
and put a passcode and be in the game.
I don't need fucking theaters.
And lemme rephrase that.
Today, you need theater still.
Kinda like I saw the
music thing 10 years ago,
now you really don't need it,
with SoundCloud, and TikTok,
things of that nature,
you don't need a label,
the way they needed it.
Now labels have to evolve
and bring more value.
Same with theaters, you
still kinda need it.
We don't have that smash movie hit
that we all went to the
website and just all watched,
and they tokenized, and
they let people share codes,
and they got their money.
But it's coming.
Don't get it twisted, it's fucking coming.
Let's keep it moving.
(laughs)
Let's fucking go.
- Let's go, baby.
- You're not joking with the GOAT shirt.
My god, Jerry Rice, what is good, man?
The legend.
It is a pleasure to see you, my friend.
Wow, I'm fired up!
- It's my pleasure, man.
- How are you?
- I'm doing great, man.
I'm honored to be on with you.
- Sure, you know what's crazy?
A lot of people love throwing around GOAT,
but my man, it's funny,
in that same draft class,
my favorite New York Jets
of all time, Al Toon,
(Jerry laughs)
and my whole life, my whole life,
I would always like, when I was a kid-kid,
I would always try to debate
that Al Toon was up to your class,
but my man, you really GOAT-ed it out.
And it's a real pleasure.
I mean, honestly, it was
really easy to choose.
I'm a AFC fan,
so it was easy when you were
killing in San Francisco.
When you came to the Raiders and did work,
we had some big games.
Like I was definitely salty,
but now I'm feeling better now
that you retired and doing other stuff,
so it's great to see you.
How are you?
- Hey, Gary, I'm good.
Look, I was pissed off because Al Toon
and Eddie brown went before me.
- I know, my man.
(Jerry laughs)
Trust me, I know that.
And I know in a very short period of time,
we took Ken O'Brien and Al Toon
before Dan Marino and Jerry Rice,
I know exactly my drafts.
(both laugh)
Listen, it's a real
pleasure to have you here.
What's on your mind?
- Hey, look, man, I just,
I have started a new company
called G.O.A.T. Fuel.
We have four drinks now.
It's a healthier drink.
And my thing over the years,
I've played the game for over 20 years,
it was all about what I put in my body.
And that gave me the opportunity
where I could go on the field and excel.
So that's what I'm trying to
do with my new energy drink.
And it's gonna be more
e-commerce right now
because of everything that's going on
with the pandemic and all of that.
- And Jerry, real quick,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
But I don't know if you
heard the last thing,
but what's funny is,
in the same way that record
labels are different,
the same thing with retailers.
Going direct to consumer is
exactly what you should do,
build it up, and then have
Walmart, and Albertsons,
and Publix, and Costco begging you for it
instead of you begging them.
You're gonna get every
meeting because of you.
I'm sure the buyers at all
these big shops are all gonna
take the Jerry Rice meeting.
(Jerry laughs)
But what I'd rather you have,
more than the legendary
status as leverage,
is actual sales to consumers.
That's gonna carry even more weight.
- Yeah.
Hello?
Okay.
- I think Gary's internet
is cut out, of course.
(Jerry laughs)
Oh, he chose to go outside.
- (laughs) I love it.
- Far away from the router.
(both laughs)
(sighs)
Hold on.
(Jerry laughs)
I'll text him.
(both laugh)
- Well, it's not me.
- No, it's definitely not you.
(Jerry laughs)
Oh, it's his computer crashed, he said.
(laughs)
Great.
- I'm talking to the legend himself
and his computer crashes.
(both laugh)
- Well, here's a fun fact.
I don't know anything about sports,
but you were the first athlete
that I ever even heard of,
because my cousin had your
San Francisco 49ers jersey on.
- Really?
- Yeah, that's all I know.
Like I didn't even know
any other athletes,
and I just saw him wear,
it said Rice on the back,
and I was like, "Who's that?"
So then I looked it up somehow,
and it was like, "It was Jerry Rice."
(laughs)
- Yeah, I can't...
God, my god, time flew by so fast, man.
- Yeah.
- I mean, over the years,
playing for 20 years,
playing with probably the
greatest quarterback with Montana,
the greatest coach, god, Bill Walsh,
and greatest owner, Eddie DeBartolo,
so we had a great ride.
- It's awesome.
What do you miss the most?
- You know, I think what I miss
the most is the camaraderie.
Going into a hostile
environment, taking up-
- I'm back, sorry about that.
- Hey, man, look, I see you're back!
- I'm back.
Listen to this.
Dustin, we have to talk to the team.
My computer's been crashing just randomly.
So, I mean, that's fine
when it's meetings here and there,
but not when we're live with the legend.
Anyway, Jerry, I totally get it.
So keep going.
What can I answer for you?
Or what's on your mind?
- You really have answered a lot for me
because we just wanted
to make it convenient
for the consumer.
And also, where they don't
pay that big overhead price
and all of that.
So I think we're moving
in the right direction.
I'm excited about the opportunity.
- Is it available for everybody right now
if they wanted to try it?
Is there a website?
- Just on the internet.
You can go to www.goatfuel.com
and you can order.
We also got apparel coming out.
So I'm excited about the whole thing.
Because you know me,
Gary, the thing about me,
I do not put my name on just anything,
I have to really believe in it.
And the thing is, I have pretty
much assembled a great team.
It's all about teamwork.
I didn't catch 1,549
balls, or 200 touchdowns,
22,895 yards,
it's all about teamwork, man.
- You're just dropping it.
- And that's it.
- Listen, let me throw something at you
that I think is gonna really work for you.
I think that you should,
and by the way, let's
get connected after this,
and we can get on a call
with you and your team,
I think that you should
create an access pack.
If everyone went to G.O.A.T. Fuel
and saw that if they bought 10 cases,
that they would get into a small group
that get an hour with Jerry on like this,
in a group to ask Q&A,
I think you can get...
You see where I'm going, my man?
- Yeah, I see where you're going.
- Access to you is so valuable.
You could go live like this digitally
and have 500 people in there,
they all bought 10 cases,
25 cases, a case a month,
I think if you layer access
because of who you are,
I mean, there's a ton of
people watching right now
who weren't gonna buy the energy drink,
even though they love you,
but the fact of be in
part of a small group,
getting a Q&A with you, access to you,
now they buy the 10 cases.
A lot of them will then,
'cause it's a lot for them,
will get out the product to their friends,
which will create word of mouth.
So I think there's a
real leverage of access.
- Yeah, and that's why I
want you on my team, man.
- Okay.
With all that knowledge
and that experience.
- Well, listen, there's a circle.
I live my whole life wishing
that you were on my team.
- (laughs) You could be my Joe Montana.
- Let's go.
Listen, let's get connected after this,
we'll have a real call.
Get your team together,
let's get my admins together,
we'll get a real meeting down.
- Okay, one more thing.
- Please.
- I'm gonna send you something out,
it's a gift because you're
a big influence, man.
And you're a GOAT.
You're the greatest
of all time.
- Thank you, man.
- And we're gonna send you a
case of G.O.A.T. Fuel, okay?
- I love it.
- Hey, man, much love.
- Dustin, let's put the URL
here for everybody to have it.
'Cause I wanna make
sure everybody does it.
Did you catch it, Dustin,
or do you need the URL?
- What is the URL again.
- G.O.A.T. Fuel.
How do you spell, Jerry?
I just wanna make sure he's catching it.
- goatfuel.com.
- Goatfuel-
- www.goatfuel.com.
Or just @goatfuel.
- I love it.
Jerry, this was such a fun surprise.
I appreciate you, my man.
It's a real, real honor.
- You got me up, I'm ready
to work out, I'm good to go.
(Gary laughs)
You see that right there,
I got my G.O.A.T. Fuel,
I'm good, man.
- Let's go.
Let's go.
Take care.
- All right, buddy.
- We'll talk soon.
- Take care.
- Thank you.
That was amazing, that fired me up.
That man is...
If you're 44 like me,
like you don't even
understand what that guy did,
like just the sheer separation
from him being the best
receiver in football
to the second best was enormous.
G.O.A.T. Fuel in the building.
There.
There it is.
Anyway, let's keep this moving.
Wow.
- Wow, what's going on?
- What's up, Simon, how are you?
- (laughs) I'm fantastic.
How are you?
- I'm quite well.
I'm quite well.
You always wear that Red Hat?
Every time I see, in content,
I see that.
- (laughs) Well, sort of.
Look at this.
- Is that your thing?
I use to...
I used to have a red hair.
And I had to shave that
off about like a month ago
because of like a stupid
YouTube challenge.
And I was bald like a month ago,
now I have a little bit of my head back,
but I'm not sure if I
wanna dye it back to red
because I don't know, I kinda
feel like not having red hair,
but then I'm like, "Uh, it's branding."
(Gary laughs)
I listen to you a lot,
branding is important.
So I think a red hat is pretty cool.
But man, like, what is this world?
You were just on the phone with like...
(chuckles) It's so crazy.
I don't know.
It's just really crazy.
But yeah.
I have a couple...
(muffled speaking)
I have a couple of questions for you.
- (laughs) Please, please.
- So like you say all the time that
it's really important to block
out any of the noise, really.
Like not to listen to
people giving you credits,
not to listen to people
who hate you and all that,
which is like-
- Or, as we continue to
mature through the process,
taking it with a grain of salt.
One of the things I worry
about when I say things like,
"Don't listen to anybody,"
is then people become
audacious and are tone-deaf.
So, what I what I mean
by that is like, look,
don't get too high, don't get too low.
When you hear information,
have the humility to admit you're wrong.
Feel nice.
When Jerry Rice says to you,
"You're the motherfucking GOAT,"
I need to take a hundredth of a second
to feel nice about that,
especially the 12-year-old me.
But the truth is, when he just said that,
it's a hundredth of a second
of like, "That's so cool,"
but then you just kinda move
on and you remind yourself,
"Yeah, but I have
shortcomings, I'm just a man."
That allows you to also,
when somebody says,
"You're a snake oil salesman
or you're a piece of shit,"
you can be compassionate
to why they say that.
They may not like the bravado of red hair,
but they don't really know you.
So it's yes, I do say tune out,
but that doesn't mean be tone-deaf.
And that's a little clarity on that.
- Okay, yeah, I think that
answers it pretty well.
Because I was, I felt like,
isn't it like a resource
that you can use to?
- 100%.
- When you get the hype,
when you get the numbers,
you just have to feel like
it pumped you the fuck up
and you're like, "Oh, man, I wanna go,
and then the next content
piece I'm gonna create,
it's gonna be like, it has a
different energy and all that."
So you just gotta research.
- Yes.
It's like ice cream,
everything in moderation.
- Yeah.
- When people are like,
"You can't have that,"
that gets a little crazy.
It's kinda like the way
parents are with alcohol.
If you look at the countries
where alcohol is demonized
and pushed very as like a negative,
you see a lot of kids,
when they get to 18 or
21 or whatever it may be,
really struggle with the
relationship with alcohol.
If you look at cultures where
alcohol is not demonized,
those kids have a much better relationship
with alcohol through their whole life.
And so I think one of the things
that I don't wanna do is
I don't wanna let other people's opinions
have too much weight,
whether it's pro or con,
because then you'll have a
better relationship with it.
- Yeah, and the better relationship
with yourself, I think.
I think, like the one thing
where I noticed where I
need to make my cut is like
my self worth needs to be
independent of everything.
- Correct.
Correct.
- The worst thing is
when you define yourself
over at numbers or any
sort of like achievement,
because it's all just work basically.
And like you just said,
the human itself needs to stay clean,
like you're just a human,
you're not gonna be any more than human,
you're never gonna be like
a superhuman or something,
but you're also not a piece of shit
when your numbers go down
or something like that.
- And you know why?
That is why,
the person that just said Russia
has a massive drinking problem,
there's an overlay on that,
which is just general depression
of the ecosystem they live in.
(Sam laughs)
Anyway, nonetheless,
what's important about, Sam, is that,
if you're really passionate
about the process,
all of a sudden, the results
don't carry the weight,
the fact that you're doing
it carries the weight.
- Yeah.
And there's like that
place of authenticity.
It's so important that you
just need to do what you like,
really like, you need to
be 100% honest yourself,
I feel like.
And if you start doing
shit to get results,
then it's always gonna kinda result
in sad sheet, yeah.
- It's always gonna fail.
It's always gonna fail.
Which is why,
which is all these different themes,
no different than that
proper gentleman who said,
"You're wrong, Gary,
Russia has a problem."
He's right about that,
but then I overlaid,
but there's another variable.
Same to this talk, which is,
all these variables
about loving the process
versus the results lets you
not worry about numbers,
or accolades, cheering, or booing.
- Yeah.
- And then if you layer another thing,
(Sam laughs)
this is why I'm spending
almost all my time
of how in the world are we
gonna make happiness the win,
not fame and money?
Like actually, how are we
gonna make that happen?
And the struggle for me is,
I, I'm most happy when
I'm buying and selling,
like garage selling sports cards.
I am my most happy as a businessman,
and I happen to be a good businessman,
so I'm not gonna be in a place
where I'm going to not not have money.
So my voice on happiness
over money is gonna blurry
because the one thing
that made me happy was actually
something that made money.
But if I had a little-
- So you're talking
about the process being
in buying and selling, right?
- Yeah.
Yes, that's what...
I don't know if you've ever
seen my garage sale videos-
- Yeah, of course, I've seen.
- It's why I'm so happy in those.
It's like waking up at 6 a.m.
to go buy something for three...
I mean, I was up at two
o'clock in the morning
the other night buying 500
Tim Hardaway Rookie Cards
for 80 cents a piece
with the hope that it's
gonna be worth $3 in a year
'cause basketball cards are going up,
and it made me so happy.
I was up at the two o'clock
in the morning doing it.
- Cool, that's awesome.
- So, I'm a merchant, I'm a tchotchke guy.
I would have been a traitor if I was,
500 years ago, I would
have been the person
that went in the woods, found
a rock, and was beautiful,
convinced the person that had sheep
that was a beautiful rock, I
got the sheep, feed my family,
it's that's my DNA.
But musicians, artists, parents, teachers,
we need more people to talk
about loving what they do.
- 100%.
- We need a famous, famous
social media teacher
who's so fucking happy,
who she or he makes 53,000 a year
and inspires an entire generation to say,
"Oh, that's it, that
happiness in the eye."
Not the 53k because, oh, by the way, 53k,
knows how to manage their money,
lives in a very lovely
home, pays their mortgage,
saves up for Disney trips,
you feel like there's so
much happiness out there
that is not being heralded.
And what we herald is business
success, fame success,
which is fine and understandable.
But if we just balanced
that with heralding people
that are happy, not
tearing down everybody,
not cancel culture,
but positivity of people that are happy.
- Yeah.
- If you're watching right now
and you're genuinely happy,
please make a video of like,
"I'm happy, I make 63,000
a year being a clerk,
I make 104,000."
Like let's tell the world
how many people are happy
that aren't millionaires,
and then shit will get very interesting.
- Yeah, absolutely, that's
a really good point.
I think, like where the
main problem lays is,
like we just said it,
is that people see definition in success
that is metricable and
stuff and measurable.
But I think we need to
get to the core of like
why people are, in the base, so unhappy,
and even have that base thought of like,
"I'm not good,
so I need to define myself
over something like numbers
or something like that."
- That's such a great point.
Like I think this gets into
self-esteem and insecurity.
This is why parenting became
a content pillar for me.
- Yeah, parenting is huge.
Parenting is like the biggest thing.
I feel like, just like in the lasts month,
I've done so much like working
out of like trauma and shit
that is based on like childhood stuff,
and I feel like that's
basically like all the reason
for all the pressure that I put on myself
in the last years
of my career.
- Yeah, 100%.
- I've been in that place
where I defined myself
over numbers and stuff.
I was fucking impressed
when it went on and stuff.
- Yeah, why are these artists doing it
that started after me?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- If you look at the two prior
comments that were below,
one gentleman was, or woman,
I couldn't tell by the name,
is unhappy making 26k.
The next gentleman,
the one who made the
point about Russia MMA,
he's thrilled at 30k.
Natasha's talking about fixing the sink.
Here's Malcolm, he's thrilled
at under 50k, that's a big...
Malcolm Dash can do a
lot more for the world
in a lot of ways than I can
at this point in my life.
If I was making content
when I was 23, 24, 25,
making 32k, 40k,
I would have crushed because
there's so much more there.
Like we need to attack this.
- Yeah, and I think
it's awesome.
- Yeah, and by the way,
that doesn't mean there isn't issues
with like separation of wealth,
there's things we have to change.
But we have to also,
we also have to,
while we're tearing down
things that aren't working,
we desperately have to build
up things that are working,
and Malcolm-fucking-Dash is working.
Like literally, that's a big fucking deal.
Malcolm, please make content
why you're happy, please.
- 100%.
- Anyway,
I appreciate you, bro.
You're on your way.
Like where your mindset is
right now is exactly right.
- Thank you, man.
Like, honestly, like I
cannot really put into words
how much of an impact like all of you
and all of your content
had like the last two
or three years.
I don't know, like it started resonating
with me more and more.
And like, by now, I'm like at the point
where like every single
video that I see, I'm like,
"Yeah," like, "Obviously,
like that's the only way that's logic,
the only way that makes sense
and stuff."
- Practical.
- And yeah, and I feel it's
still so much the opposite
of what everyone else
in the world basically thinks is right.
So, I feel like, man,
we need to wake people up.
So yeah,
good on you, man, keep going.
- Awesome, I wish you well.
I will, Sam, take care, thank you.
- Bye-bye.
- (laughs) Look at this rock, we're rich.
It's true Brandon.
Like I'm actually genuinely
curious if I "crack"
and just become a garage seller
and baseball card dealer.
I don't think it's impossible.
I enjoy too many other things I'm doing,
but I don't know, man.
Anyway, let's keep it going.
Woow!
- Woow!
- You got the whole crew.
- We got the whole crew, man.
- Momo Shack, what's good?
- Momo Shack, what's up, man?
Thank you so much for having us, dude.
I think I wanna start off by just saying,
thank you from the bottom of our hearts
for doing what you do.
In a world where we are
constantly being told how to act
or how to be a certain way,
you're preaching the opposite,
there's strength in who we are,
and we gotta give that to our colleagues.
So thank you so much, man.
- You're welcome.
- That's a big time of
like who Momo Shack is
and why we do certain things.
- Where is Momo Shack?
- So we're based out of Dallas, Texas.
- I love it.
- Also a big shout out to Zain, man,
we go way, way, way back, 2015.
I don't know if you know this,
but he was the freshman orientation lead
when I was first getting into college.
- I didn't know that.
- Yeah, man, he's a huge supporter.
So love that guy.
- It's awesome.
What can I answer for you?
- Sure.
So, before we get to
the question real quick,
just wanna provide a bit of context.
So, in this call right now,
we're representing three
different countries.
So I'm from Nepal.
My name is Lobsang.
And this is my mom, Chef Minu,
head chef.
- Chef Minu.
- Yeah, we're both from Nepal.
And then-
- I'm Thung, I'm from Vietnam.
- And I'm Daniel, from Mexico.
- Yeah, so we rep that
immigrant life like hard,
like we really vibe with it.
And I think growing up here,
the biggest thing for us was,
the focus was going
through that societal path
of go to college, get a good job.
So that was our focus.
So we went to college, that's
where our stories connect,
that's where I met these guys.
And then I happen to graduate
just a semester earlier
than them-
- Making Mama Chef proud.
- Exactly.
(Gary laughs)
Yeah, that's big.
And then got the corporate
job, made it to corporate.
And as I was going
through the daily motions
of learning and things like that,
I think something in me
clicked and I was like,
"Oh, I thought I made it, but
I don't quite feel it yet."
So I would relay the same
message to these guys,
and we would like huddle up,
brainstorm, come up with ideas.
Fast forward to December
2017, we found your content,
and then we just decided to execute.
By no means do we know what we're doing,
or did we know what we
were doing at that time,
but we did it.
- Nobody knew it.
- Exactly.
The only the only reason I'm further along
in some ways is because I
started doing it at six.
The only reason at 44
I can have this kind of
entrepreneurial juice is I was,
unlike you delivered for
your mom, I kind of didn't.
I did, but I didn't for school,
because I went completely,
which is crazy in hindsight,
but I've been a businessman
now for 38 years for real.
Like it's all I've ever thought about.
And so I've so many reps.
But at six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, I mean,
I was making mistakes when I was 17,
I made a mistake last week.
Me and AJ were talking yesterday
about major mistakes that
we're both making right now.
Nobody knows what they're
doing in the beginning.
That's the best part of
doing, instead of learning.
Teaching and watching me
or going to business school is great,
but it's zero compared to living it.
Zero.
- Absolutely, experience
is the best teacher,
no, we feel that.
So, yeah, 2017, we started
off as a pop-up brand.
So going direct to consumers,
like you were talking
about with Jerry earlier.
And then with COVID naturally happening,
we had to find a way to pivot.
So now we're doing package Momo.
So if you check out our IG,
you'll see the little bag.
And we're doing pickup
orders with customers.
- Are you shipping?
- Not yet, no, we're just-
- Can you?
Or you lose too much in
the shipping process?
- I think we're gonna lose too much
just 'cause it's frozen goods, right?
- I have an idea.
I've been sitting on this idea,
I'm gonna share it with you.
Do you feel like your recipe
is a secret in any way or no?
- Absolutely.
- I'm trying to figure out
how people can send deconstruction boxes.
So, like I love this idea that,
I have a good feeling
that thousands of people
right now would literally buy
a deconstructed dumpling box from you,
that then, every Friday night,
from six to 9 p.m., Eastern,
which would catch everybody, kind of,
you're doing live cooking with Mama Chef,
with you three characters,
and people are actually making
dumplings along with you.
Now, the fun part is you're like,
look, this is gonna be you,
these are official Momos,
because we have a little secret,
Mama, do the secret thing.
Like let's not show her right
now, you like move it away.
All right, Mama is doing the secret stuff,
all right, now we're back.
I think there's a way
for you to build a brand
that isn't directly selling what you sell,
but, all of a sudden,
I've just taken you to a national brand
instead of a local brand.
And I think you could
actually sell a shitload
of fucking "maker packs."
I think it's a big idea,
and I think for a lot of people out there
that don't have some secret
to their ingredients,
it's a huge idea.
Thoughts?
- No, absolutely.
I mean, on the whiteboard here,
we actually have that written
down as one of the next things
that we wanted to tackle,
which is like DIY-
- Move that idea to the top
of that fucking whiteboard.
- For sure.
Thank you, man.
Yeah, and then, I think like
piggybacking off of that,
our question was gonna be,
like knowing what you know now,
let's say you're the CEO of Momo Shack,
what are some like
tactical immediate things
that you would focus on?
And what are some
macro-level vision things
that you would focus on in
the next five to 10 years
to make that a nationwide brand?
- I would decide if I wanna do franchising
or if I wanna own.
That's number one.
You have to make that
decision in your game.
And by the way, there's no right decision.
You need to be self-aware
and figure out it yourself.
Number two, I would create the
deconstructing dumplings pack
and sell it to everybody
in the country. (laughs)
I really am hot on this.
I think local brands can go national
when they don't think they can.
Somebody makes ice cream,
ship out ice cream makers
and do videos with people
at night making ice cream.
It won't be exactly your ice cream,
but your brand is gonna get huge.
If you're a winery, and you're small,
and you're in Texas, for example,
which is an emerging wine
region, create wine making kits.
That's months of content
'cause shit sits in the ground,
in the garage, excuse me.
I'm very hot on that.
And then the other thing
I would do is immediately
become a media company.
You're immediate company that
happens to sell dumplings.
And what I mean by that is,
when I see this foursome,
this is incredible inspiration
for not only immigrants,
for not only brown
people, for white people,
for black people, for all types.
And I think a podcast, or a
documenting, either a vlog,
and I know you know this,
I say this all the time,
watch what I do, not what I say.
The answer to your questions
are in my own behavior.
This is why, like to me,
the reason to watch me,
at some point,
the concept of what I'm
talking about is gonna click,
whether it's the first time you hear me,
or a year or two later,
and you start off not liking
me, but then it clicked.
It will because it's way bigger than me,
I just happen to message it.
The bigger reason I think
people should follow me is
they should do what I'm doing.
I think you should do a
coffee show every morning
with your small little group,
named after the same
concept as Tea with GaryVee.
After three months of it, all of a sudden,
people are coming to buy to
buy coffee in the mornings
and dumplings at night,
now you've become a restaurant
that has multiple times of the day period.
You could become the
number one coffee player
in your local area 'cause
you did a coffee show
and you talk about testing.
The whole show is 100 days
of you trying different
coffee beans that you bought.
And you're doing Q&A and just
talking about Dallas culture,
immigrant culture, the
Mavericks, I don't give a fuck.
And then, all of a sudden,
people know you as the coffee person
even though that you're Momo Shack,
and, all of a sudden, now
you're selling coffee,
and now the local news wants
to cover you because like,
"Get this story,
a dumpling shop is now beating
out Starbucks in Dallas.
Let's talk..."
You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- A fucking strategy.
- Man, yeah, that's huge.
Absolutely.
I think we'll hop on that ASAP.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Awesome.
Good luck.
- Cool.
- Everybody follow the Shack.
- Momo Shack.
- One last question, Gary.
- Yeah, sure, sure.
Go ahead.
- So it's kinda crazy
right now due to COVID,
so like offices are close,
but, man, we love to do a catering event
with the VaynerMedia.
- Done.
It's done.
- Yeah?
- Awesome.
Yes.
- 2021, I'll make sure...
Well, I gotta figure out how
not to like pick favorites.
I mean, it's probably
gotta be in New York,
but I might wanna do it in LA.
Let me give you some thought.
Or maybe we'll do both,
and then we'll do like a whole,
and I'll make sure it's
part of my weekly vlog
to give you tons of exposure.
Because you're doing that nice thing,
I wanna return tenfold,
so we'll lock it in.
You'll work with Zain,
we'll get that done.
- Let's go!
- Lovely plan.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, Gary,
we love you.
- But if you don't bring
Mama, you're not coming.
- She's coming.
(crosstalk drowns out speaker).
- See yah.
All right, let's keep rocking it.
Man, there's just something
about the energy of the show.
Oh!
Hi?
- I've been documenting my starting,
or about to talk with
GaryVee on TikTok. (laughs)
- I love it, Laura.
And hi, baby, how are you?
- Good.
Yeah.
We added two silent Es to the
end of his name in your honor.
- You're very sweet. (laughs)
- And we got some swag on today.
Actually, there's a fun story.
This is the first piece of baby
clothing that I ever bought.
And we actually got it like two years
before we even had him.
And it happens to-
- What does it say?
- When we talked.
So it's kinda cool.
- What does it say?
- It's the hustler one.
- I love it.
You're very sweet.
I see it.
You're so sweet.
I'm so honored.
What can I answer for you?
- Yeah, well, first of all,
I want to say a specific
thing that I've really noticed
I haven't heard someone call you out on.
And that is,
you always give both
genders in your examples
when you're talking about the next CEO,
the next app developer, or whatever.
And for me, I'm similar to you,
I grew up in the '80s and '90s.
And every fucking textbook
had examples of only men,
only white men.
And it's easy to grow up thinking,
"Gosh, I guess women
and people of color didn't do anything."
So I notice that from you,
and I really appreciate it.
- Thank you for saying that.
- My pleasure.
So, in preparing for this,
I've been listening over and over
to two specific tea segments
that I kinda wanna see
how you could maybe help me
apply to a bit of a variation
that I wanna take now with my business
because some of my priorities
have really changed now
that I'm a new mommy.
So, Tom Levine, you talked with him,
he's a good fiction writer,
you gave him the advice, like
a $5 a month subscription app
that's helping people
with fiction writing.
And then Melissa from ItFits Bars,
you had the idea of-
- Access.
- Yeah, access, but you get
it like on top of the bar.
- Ironically, it's what
I just told Jerry Rice
to do as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. (laughs)
Totally.
So my background is I
was a big nerd in school.
I totally bought in, unlike you,
I bought into the whole
academics is the recipe.
So I was just a nerd, went
to the best college I could.
And at 20, I studied abroad
in Germany for a year
and read "Rich Dad, Poor Dad,"
and those two things just blew up my world
'cause I was like,
"Oh, I didn't even know you
could start businesses,"
and even occur to me,
and then traveling the world and all that.
So, in my '20s, I couldn't
figure out business
'cause the internet wasn't like it is now.
And I tried a bunch of stuff,
funny failure stories that went nowhere.
And I ended up going back to what I know,
which is education, so I was a teacher.
So I taught high school
math and psychology
for about five years.
- And psychology?
- Yeah, yes.
- That's cool.
- My undergrad, I started
as an English major,
and switched to psychology in undergrad.
- Cool.
- Yeah.
And then, at age 30, so that's
nine years ago, I was like,
"Okay, that's it, I love teaching."
I was super happy even
though I wasn't making a time
'cause I was traveling the world
and I'm smart with money,
just like you said earlier,
but I just had this burning desire,
like I have to figure out
this entrepreneur thing.
So, it's been a long
journey, these nine years,
I had a lot of things to learn,
and a lot of things to unlearn.
I used to edit out contractions
from people's emails
on my team because I was
like, "That's not official."
And now, I put them if we
wanna speak conversational.
- Right, I can't even spell, so I get it.
Go ahead.
- So I really started
kinda hitting my stride
and figuring my sorta niche.
In 2016, started a podcast
called Copy That Pops.
So it's like writing that
stands out for business,
and psychology tips and hacks.
- Yep.
- And then at the end of the year,
I had three people I
really respect tell me,
"Why don't you write a book?
You have a writing as your
superpower for nonfiction,
so why don't you have a book?"
And I was like, "Oh, I thought
I had wait for permission,"
and decided to like fuck
that, let's just go.
So I wrote and self-published a book,
it's over 360 pages, in 30 days, (laughs)
and figured out
how to hit number one
bestseller categories in Amazon.
And after that, people
started asking me for help
to do the same thing,
is to writing and self-publishing
and doing fun launches,
and then using their books
to get more speaking gigs
and more podcast interviews
and all this stuff.
So that's what I've been doing.
So, specifically nonfiction,
and helping entrepreneurs to
write-self published books.
But now that I've got this guy,
(child giggling)
I'm even more passionate about
what goes in kids' heads and kids' worlds.
- Make sense.
- Specifically clothing.
'Cause when I was doing like
baby showers, I was planning,
I would not reveal the gender
because I didn't want an
explosion of pink or blue.
And it seems like with kids clothes,
like that's all there is, is
like super gender stereotypes,
which drives me absolutely insane.
And I want there to be
more like business-related,
fun stuff to handle, like what you did.
So I'm really passionate about,
and then also kids books.
I think there needs to be
more diversity, inclusiveness,
multi-everything.
- Here's the best part of the internet
and just the world we live in.
Everything you're passionate
about, you can execute.
- No, totally, I'm 100% going to.
My question more for you is like,
how could I uniquely
structure that, maybe,
as a combination of
maybe like kids clothes,
kids books that are
business-related and diverse,
and maybe an access model?
I'm kinda trying to-
- I see.
I think what I'm hearing is more
of just the question of like what,
from the beginning of it,
will give it a more likelihood of success?
- Yeah.
So where I've made most of my money
in the past few years is
high-end private clients.
- Good.
- I don't wanna do that
anymore just because he-
- Yeah, he takes up your time, of course.
- So I'm kind of trying
to explore more products and group access.
- I got it.
I got it.
Yeah, I think, look, here's the good news.
I think you're on it.
The reason I keep bringing
up group access is
'cause I think it's a big business idea.
I think if you start a infrastructure
around clothes and books
and access to you for three hours a week,
Monday eight to nine, obviously,
his schedule is gonna
change as he goes through.
So you'll have to figure
out what works for you.
And it might be just one hour,
nine to 10 on Friday, p.m., one hour.
But, yes, I think starting
a business that says,
"This is my business,
it is going to be diverse and inclusive,"
whether it's kids with disability,
whether it's background,
that's amazing,
and obviously, very much
on the consciousness
of at least half the country
and many more than that,
for that matter.
And so, I think there's a lot
of business opportunity there.
And I think access is
gonna be the biggest lever.
I do believe that access is
the emerging leverage point.
And so I think it's a
book and clothes club
with the person that is the person.
Like imagine the first
time Harry Potter came out
if she was available.
Obviously, she's in the news a lot now
for a lot of different things.
But like, people want access.
Period, end of story.
If my next book that I write comes with,
if you buy this book,
there's a unique barcode
on the back of every book,
and you get to be part of a closed...
(laughs)
See, Baby E likes this idea.
(Laura laughs)
And so, yes, I actually think
you have it figured out.
I think reverse engineer how much time
you're willing to give,
and then you'll be able to amortize.
You're not gonna be able
to have high-end clients paying you 1,000,
you're gonna have a lot
more people paying you 50,
but the good news is, it's scalable.
The high-end clients,
whether you're charging
them 1,000 or 500,000,
you can only have so
many, you just one woman.
A super woman, but like one woman.
I think that if you go to the $50 access
instead of the $1,000,
I don't know your numbers,
it might be $10, it might be five,
but I think you'll get
to that income level,
and it's gonna cost you an hour
instead of costing you
all that other time.
And I think you've set it
up that way from day one.
It's almost like Costco.
From day one, you can buy my
book, you can buy my shirt,
but, (laughs) he's so damn cute,
but there's this really epic thing
that gives you this access,
and I think you'll see 80%,
50%, 30% sign up for that,
and that will be the trigger.
- And what do you think on pricing?
Like with ItFits Bars, it was like 72,
then you're like, "No, 99
for a 12-pack, plus access."
Do you have any ideas on that?
- I do, I do.
A couple of things.
If you go the route of
selling the book or cloths
without the access,
you may have a lot of people that then say
you're not worth the extra 100 bucks.
So, you've gotta first make a decision of,
do I build a model where you only...
I love this, you got GaryVee,
Baby E, and a fucking bee.
I mean, this is just like perfect.
- Or his favorite. (laughs)
- I love it.
- And a hand like you.
- (laughs) I love it.
So I really think that you need to decide
if you're gonna sell the books
or clothes outside of access.
I would actually recommend not,
because then, you can bundle the fee.
So, now all of a sudden,
the books are $55
when everybody knows
the book is really 15,
but what comes along with that book is
you're part of this group, and
we're here every single week,
52 weeks a year, for these two hours live,
here's the passcode.
And I think you should sell it yourself,
this way, you have the email,
so that you can give them access.
You don't have to worry about the code
that I just talked about.
That's how I would
structure as far as pricing.
I think people would absolutely,
I think $100 a month is
an incredible price point.
So, if they get a book
and a piece of clothing
that normally would have been 40 bucks,
and that you that now
are making that extra 60,
and you can make that, think about that.
If you're at $60, and
you get 1,000 people,
if you grind hard for a couple years,
now you've got $60,000 in
monthly recurring revenue.
- Right.
- That you're probably
making 20,000 in profit
because you gotta make the
book and what have you,
now I think you've got something.
- Very cool.
- And then you can tear it
because somebody could
buy a month for 140,
somebody could buy six
months for a buck-10,
or a year for 99.
You're all in for 50 on your hard goods,
on the book and the clothes, per month,
maybe they get a book
and a piece of clothing,
but what the real game
is, is this access thing.
And then you're putting
out content constantly
because then people are
buying into your access.
I mean, this is never gonna
be the route I'm gonna go
because I'm making my
economics differently,
but I don't begrudge it
when somebody is bringing
value with access.
And I have a funny feeling,
if I ask people how much they would pay
for a month for a bottle of wine with me,
and having that small
access, it would be high.
Leave in the comments
what your number would be,
and don't make it up,
it's just good data for everybody
who's watching right now,
for them to think about
how they can do it.
So don't say 1,000 or whatever,
put what you would actually put.
So that's what I see, Laura.
- And would you take
like those hour sessions
and chop them up and do like your 64
or your 200 or whatever
pieces of content from those?
- Yes, I would.
Yes, I would.
Because it's the same
thing I do with the 4Ds.
That's a $12,000 VaynerMedia
product, but I put it out.
So like, yes, I would.
- 4Ds are my favorite
stuff for Tea with GaryVee,
'cause you're like you're flying
as well as listening to it.
- Yeah, you're learning.
- Yeah.
- And the same thing, there I
have time, here I have time,
and I think that's why it's working.
So awesome.
Bye.
Bye, baby.
- And one more request.
- Go ahead.
- If we get out to New York,
could we come by for the day?
- Yeah.
- Everything shared, we
can right a book about it?
- Yes.
- Yay!
Thank you. (laughs)
- Talk to Dustin, or Zain, or
whoever, to set you up here.
- Okay, I will.
Thank you, Gary.
- Bye-bye.
Thank you.
That was fun.
Let's keep it moving.
London Martinez, 1,200,
I might have to do that.
That's 14,000 a year.
(Donah gasping and clapping)
Hi.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Oh, my god!
I'm so excited that I'm here.
- Thank you.
What's your name?
- Oh, my god, I'm Donah.
- Donah.
- How are you?
- I'm so well.
It's so nice to see, Donah.
- You too.
I just wanna say, thank you so much.
You have been like amazing.
I love the way you are with people
and how much you give
and how much you offer.
And it's just, oh, my god, I'm gonna cry.
(laughs)
- Thank you, Donah.
- It's so awesome.
- Where do you live?
- I live in Charlotte, but
I'm a New Yorker originally.
So I've been here for quite a long time.
So I wanted to get on here
and talk to you because,
well, a couple of things.
So I'm one of those people
that I listened to you every single day
throughout the whole
lockdown, every single day,
and I discovered you
probably this year, I think.
And so, just to give a little backstory,
when I first moved here,
when living in New York, it was
all about the more you know,
the more diversified you are,
the better candidate you are for a job
or anything you wanna do.
Moving to South,
I felt like I started
to get put into a box
that I had to focus on one thing.
The problem is,
is I am so multifaceted that I turned
into some time like this crazy professor,
obsessed that I will get 1,000
different ideas at one time.
- That's good.
- So, when I moved here, I
had a graphic design business.
I'm a single parents,
and I had a child that was really sick.
And so I started teaching
yoga, I did everything I could.
I started a graphic design business.
I was a mindfulness coach back then
when there was no such
thing as mindfulness.
Now, it's like a big deal.
I owned an herbal body care company,
where I created all the
products myself from scratch.
I formulated everything.
And, at that time,
nobody really knew what Hemi products were
or robotic care products were.
Not like now, everybody's doing it.
So I spent a lot of time educating people.
And at the end of the day,
my products did pretty well,
but I got really burnt.
- Yeah, of course,
it happens.
- And I was making it,
creating education, I was
doing training programs.
I mean, I just got burnt out.
And I ran out of money,
and I had to go back to
work to relieve my mind
as well make money.
- It's totally the same.
And by the way, Donah, that's good.
I really hope you understand
and I hope everybody on earth understands,
that's not an L, that's
part of the process.
- Yeah.
- It's very important
that you do not look at that as a loss.
I mean that.
- Well, thank you.
Less plenty, and it was hard. (laughs)
- In the micro, it was a loss.
In the macro, it was a win,
because now, at this
still young of an age,
and you know I believe this shit,
you and I are younger than we think.
- But I'm older, I'm 52.
So when you say I have a lot of years,
I feel like I don't have a lot of time.
- First of all,
you look fucking fantastic,
for 52.
- Thank you.
- Number two,
number two, you just do.
I'm just gonna play this
out for you, listen.
And every time I say this,
I always see somebody
commented or they'll email me,
"What if she gets cancer?"
Yes, I understand things happen.
I also understand it's extremely likely
that we're talking about 38, 42 years
with the way medicine is progressing.
You know, that's a long
fucking time, Donah.
Like 38 years ago, you were 14.
- Yeah.
- A lot of shit has happened
since you were 14.
- Yeah.
- So, when you start looking at that way,
so anyway, nonetheless,
I just really wanna make
sure that that experience
that you went through,
it's a building block.
Yes, it was a loss, but you didn't lose.
And people need to understand that.
But keep going.
- So going back to work
has been hard for me
because I tend to get put
in a box all the time.
Even when I worked for other companies,
they see me as a fix it.
I'm really good at fixing things
and clearing out operations.
I'm in retail, and so I'm always going,
and I fixed the stories,
and I make them profitable,
and make them run.
- Love.
- I'm really usually ready to get out,
but then I end up stuck there.
So, anyway, during this lockdown
time, I listened to you,
I started a YouTube channel,
I'm on TikTok, Instagram,
LinkedIn, everywhere.
And I have to tell you that,
even back then,
I started a YouTube channel back then
when YouTube was not a
big thing, I started,
I have blogs still sitting out there.
But somewhere along the
line, something that happens,
I get all this inspiration
with 1,000 ideas.
I love beauty, and then
I love mindfulness,
and then I really believe
that one of my purposes is,
is to help the world see things
from different perspectives.
So George Floyd happened.
I started doing videos on George Floyd
and helping people to
start talking about race
and how we can heal as a world.
I've done videos of beauty
and I get all these different ideas.
And they feel like they're
in so many different paths,
but I can't figure out how
to bring it all together.
- You don't bring them all together.
- Well, on YouTube,
I watch a lot of videos
on what to do with,
and they say,
you should have one thing
that you're talking about.
No, they're saying that-
- But I don't know how
to do it all.
- Donah?
- Then I get tired.
- Donah, they're telling
you how to win on YouTube.
I'm trying to have you win in life.
- Okay.
- Like stick with me here.
Like when you go through this process,
when you say, how to
bring them all together,
you don't bring them all together.
You're the all together.
- Right.
- You are the part that
brings it all together.
- Right.
- Like you, the human.
You, the unique human, is
how it all comes together.
The bigger question is-
- I don't think later
that I might talk about
a face cream one day-
- I'm talking about
baseball cards out here.
Donah, I'm talking about
sports cards out here.
(Donah laughs)
I'm talking
about billionaire companies
reaching out to me saying,
"Are you okay?"
Literally, I had venture
capitalists reaching out
to me saying, "Are you okay?"
when they saw me make videos
of going garage selling.
They're like, "Are you okay?"
I'm like, "What the fuck
are you talking about?
Of course I'm okay."
- Right.
- Like I'm talking about the Jets,
I'm talking about social media,
I'm talking about sports cards,
I'm talking about wrestling,
I'm talking about
business, entrepreneurship,
corporate life, I'm
talking about parenting,
I'm talking about TikTok,
you're what brings it together.
The bigger question is,
are you worried that by doing
so many different things
that make you happy 'cause
you're wildly creative,
'cause that's what it is,
that you're concerned
that by not having some...
But that doesn't allow
you to maximize dollars
that allows you to have stability
to be at peace to be able to do it.
- Right, so that I get
at it by day time thing.
- Yeah, so let's talk about it.
I got it.
- 'Cause even TikTok, like,
honestly, Gary, TikTok,
if I do something on
TikTok that I'm talking,
no one really pays me attention.
So here I'm 52, we're trying
to learn all these dances,
and I have like all these followers,
but they're all men,
that's not getting me anywhere.
You know what I mean?
- (laughs) Listen.
(Donah laughs)
Listen, there's definitely some baggage
that comes along with
being pretty, I get it.
(Donah laughs)"
Listen to me.
Donah, listen.
I'm the same as you.
What I have that has made
it work is the ability
to make one thing 80%.
But go at it 110%, which
gives me 20% to play.
VaynerMedia is my 80%.
- Right.
- GaryVee.
Sports cards, garage
selling, social media,
that's the 20%.
I go hard at both,
but I think what you need
is to find your 80% thing.
And in a world where there's
a lot of things you can do,
it's literally, literally,
rolling the dice
or throwing a dart or flipping a coin.
You have so many patents.
I think that you need to really think
about having one core
main thing, the steak,
and then side dish everything else,
or don't eliminate the side dishes,
because they're the things that allow you
to focus on the main thing.
My baseball card, sports card thing,
GaryVee,
all of that are the things that allow me
to actually be a very
good CEO for VaynerMedia.
Because if I didn't have this side stuff,
I wouldn't be able to be happy
'cause I would burn out from VaynerMedia
'cause my brain would
wanna do other things.
I allow myself to do other things
at what is perceived as
the shortcoming of the 80%.
But those other things allow
me to be 110% on the 80.
Does that make sense?
- Right.
- So I think you need to
pick the sustainable thing,
the thing that you love.
- You mean like a YouTube
thing, sustainable,
or a topic sustainable?
- A business sustainable.
- Oh, sustainable, yeah.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- You don't have to be
so you don't have to do the...
You need to be able to get out
and do your thing at all times.
You need to pick one thing
that pays your bills enough-
- Right, that's what's
I'm trying to figure out.
- I see.
(Donah laughs)
That's what want for you.
Because once you are selling
candles direct to consumer,
or start an access business
like I'm talking about,
once you do that,
you're gonna be then able to
be a little bit more creative
and play with social media
and do other side things
and talk about meditation
or racial justice.
But you need the thing that
is your oxygen, your well,
that allows everything else to happen,
but you're gonna need those
other things to happen.
The people that tell you to
focus on one thing are wrong,
because you're wired to need
the other stuff, like me.
- Yes, yes.
- But the part that
you're missing right now,
good news, we've got 52
more years to drill this,
(Donah laughs)
is I need you to build something
that is Sustainable as your one thing,
but not cut off everything
because then that's holding your breath,
and you're gonna eventually breathe,
and the whole thing's gonna break.
So, you need to build a sustainable thing,
but still do 20% of the side stuff.
- Right.
- But you've gotta figure out
what that sustainable thing is.
- Right, that's what I'm
trying to figure out.
Because I was thinking
I could maybe go back
to making some products again,
even if it's one thing,
'cause, I mean, full time job,
it's hard to make as many
things as I did before,
if I started with one or two things,
and then building it from there.
- What has historically
given you the most success?
- Sorry?
- Out of all the things you've ever done,
what was the thing that
maybe worked the best?
- Oh.
- On a solo level.
Anything?
- On the soul level?
- On the solo, not soul.
Not soul.
Not love, no, like
actual business success.
What's the most successful
thing you've done
as an entrepreneur versus as a executive?
- I think my herbal body
care company did the most.
- And what burnt you out from that?
And what ended up happening really there?
- It's that, first of all,
when you're making stuff
from home, manufacturing,
I couldn't grow it enough,
I didn't have the money.
And I actually went back to school
and got my MBA thinking that
was the problem. (laughs)
- Yeah, I get it.
I get it.
- Trying to get more education.
So it was really trying to,
you need money in order to grow
because you can only manufacture
so much from your home.
You know what I mean?
- But you could also start a
business that does pre-selling.
- Yeah.
- You could sell futures.
A lot of people that don't have dollars,
don't realize the thing
they have is their passion
and their clout and a business model
that takes the money before it comes in.
- Yeah, okay.
- If you came out
and said, "This soap is gonna be $25,
but if you order it now,
which comes in several
months, it'll be 15,"
all of a sudden,
you can take those dollars
and you can manufacture more that way.
- That's good idea.
- I think so.
And you're gonna be at the mercy
of how much people trust you.
And obviously, not
everyone's gonna trust you,
but enough people are gonna trust you
to allow you to do that.
- Right.
- Pre-sell.
- Okay, that's a good idea.
- Thank you.
I have one more, I do
have one more question.
- I have a client meeting in one minute.
- Okay.
Can I take my videos and turn
the audio into a podcast?
Do you think that's a good idea?
Or do I need to have to set my podcast?
- You mean the thing that I do?
- Yeah.
Well, yeah. (laughs)
- Yes, you could do it.
- Okay.
All right, great.
Oh, you froze.
Thank you so much.
- I think he crashed again, but-
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Just tell him thank you.
Much love to him.
Thank you so much for everything.
- No problem.
- You guys have a great day.
- You too.
- All right.
- Okay.
Well, Gary's computer crashed again.
So I guess I'll just end the show for him.
(laughs)
Thank you everyone for watching.
I'll read some of the comments.
Thank you to People With a Passion.
It's going too fast.
DJ Kingpin.
Anyway, Gary's gotta go to a meeting,
so I don't think he's gonna make it back.
And thanks, everyone, for watching.
Please, come here back tomorrow.
We're gonna have,
the sports card episode is tomorrow.
What else?
(laughs)
Watch this.
Oh, go follow GaryVee TV on Twitter.
And I'm gonna play this promo
so you can figure out what that is.
And, yeah, see you tomorrow.
Bye-bye.
- And the people that are gonna win
over the next five
to seven years are gonna
be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
(upbeat music)
You don't love the process.
This is rules that we're talking about.
Gary views requires sacrifice.
All of your actions have
to then map your way.
Backpack, backpack, backpack.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work,
it's being respectful,
it's being a good person.
Do that, that's just a good idea.
It's there, the flip thing is there.
This house right here,
there's $400,00 to be made.
I stay in my lane.
Like real fucking tight.
But you can't be crippled.
Everybody here is judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing 'cause you're laying
in your bed looking at
somebody's fucking glamorous,
photoshopped picture of
them doing something cool,
and you're envious, and you're jealous,
and you're impatient, and
it's crippling your upside.
Lemme just say it one more
time if you're confused
of what I just said.
I say, put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five-year window of your life.
My only answer to me or anybody,
it's just like, just try shit.
Turn your boggles down,
and go work for an apparel
company for 3 years.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed
up, you better work harder,
you better work smarter.
If you can't google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
GaryVee TV, my new account.
Check me out.
Hope you enjoy it.